okay i'm gonna just tell you guys this
because i know i've taken this public
transport system this is los angeles
okay this is the blue line which i think
goes to
long beach it goes to long beach it goes
to long beach i have to think of long
beach griffin okay it goes to one yeah
shout out to him so this goes to long
beach if you've never taken this train
as someone who's taken it myself when i
used to live there that is a [ __ ]
shitty train i've seen so many fights
break out the craziest homeless people
you could ever imagine so she's sitting
at a train station i guess this is
unfolding
and so [ __ ] are rolling up on
her
what does that mean means no i'm
underage just don't
[Music]
she said no
she done said no
[ __ ] move on
she don't have to talk to you how you
doing no wow
take your l
skedaddle i look at you funny when she
says she's underage and you keep trying
to talk to her yes what is wrong with
you
but if we're being honest a lot of the
individuals you're going to see on these
trains have mental health issues to the
utmost degree i'm not saying this is it
because we can't chop chop up every
situation where dudes are going after
women
i'm not doing that no but i'm saying
we're i've taken this train i'm telling
you this right now you won't have people
unstable people at least approach
anybody but it's especially dangerous
for women but even when they're not they
don't have mental issues and stuff like
that facts people approach like the oh
my god yo it you know whatever it's
spring that comes on in in new york you
know what you call that
hey yo my yeah well [ __ ] you dan season
that's what it is
well yeah that's what the season is hey
yo ma come here for a minute hey [ __ ]
you dan you ugly anyways that's what it
is it's like ugh
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] is nasty but let's
just keep going
merry christmas though my bad yeah why
are you happy to you
you don't like black people
[Music]
bro this is not good pop it's not good
cop bad cop
this is a good weinstein bad weinstein
that's what this is that's good
weinstein buy one this is creepy as hell
bro yeah
at night time taking public transport
they're late be like this it'd be like
this in a lot of places
hold up you look at the runner says
ignoring them didn't work because she
wasn't replying for a bit yeah neither
did the underage car no fax
so sometimes so it's like you know you
tell people don't lie but if lying is
the alternative to violence then lie
your way out of it say you got a
boyfriend i'm mad at you say you're
taken say you're married say your hijabi
say you got aids i don't care what you
have to say i approve of those lies
dudes be like well you don't have to lie
yes she did yes you have to lie because
telling you guys the truth that they're
not interested is too much of an ego
blow for a lot of loser men out there
yeah right so it's preferable them to
lie because a lot of dudes will respect
the women more if they find out she's
taken than if she says she's not
interested she tells the truth oh [ __ ]
you got a boyfriend when i ain't jealous
yay
this is like that weird creepy [ __ ] bro
this is why when i'm hanging out with
dudes
and i remember this in high school a lot
i felt super uneasy and weirded out when
dudes would do the whole cat calling
yeah well they would yell
yeah and it wouldn't be like they would
follow him like hey mom well do you just
yell that no like what y'all do i'll
check i'll check you on the spot
i can't hang with you you can't be seen
together bro you mean
[ __ ] out of here why are you doing that
like that you're old as [ __ ] you're
coming over here i'm [ __ ] 16 years
old leave me the [ __ ] alone
that's that simple i told you i'm
underage you don't [ __ ] listen
all right
yeah god damn
pain
god damn you so aggressive
oh my god who raised you
who [ __ ] raised you i'm sorry are you
excited to put up with your [ __ ] right
now yes
[Music]
beautiful women ain't nothing wrong with
that i said i'm not in the mood so
please don't
[ __ ] your mood
celeste
take your ass back to your country it's
late maybe we'll get the [ __ ]
everybody
[Music]
so a lot of women are watching this like
yeah i deal with that all the
time higher mountains you guys i've seen
this
more times than i here's the worst thing
that happens
remember i was telling you like this
[ __ ] some of them were just like
crazy unstable
obviously dudes intervene and then a
fight breaks out yeah and then weapons
get pulled really fast okay yeah and
then night gets
decimated yeah
and it's like there's no easy thing out
of this right there's no easy to think
of this
i say la and i bring up the mental
health issues and stuff like that a lot
just because if you've ever taken the
public transport in los angeles
specifically okay
there's crazy people everywhere like
legitimately these are people who are
unstable it's clear they need
psychiatric help it's clear that they're
homeless you know that's a whole
problem in it of itself and it's like
how do you even reason with somebody
like that
you can't
right she tried
she tried but these people were just
unhinged or maybe they were they were
drunk and it was just regular i can't
say for sure so i don't want to chalk it
up to that
but it's important for fellows to
realize that yo ladies go through this
all the time and it's one of those tough
things we just trying to live a regular
life you just trying to go home or maybe
go see your friends you take your public
transport and it's unsafe it makes you
not want to leave the house right it
makes you not want to leave listen i'll
be honest with you i leave my house all
the time
at late hours even in shitty places and
yes it's a tad bit unsafe for me but
it's not on their level
certainly not
right first off i look dusty some people
don't even want to come up on me unless
they think i got money and i never look
like i got money y'all know how i dress
i look like i'm homeless too it's great
i just try to look menacing
that works for him you know
we all got our techniques homelessness
menacing
it works well
but for ladies they don't have that out
the moment these [ __ ] realize
you got so sometimes you see these
ladies to be wearing baggy ass clothes
trying to hide everything
i'm not mad at them because if they
dress any type of way [ __ ] come
up well you were dressed like that
that's what you wanted talking about
what the [ __ ]
this this woman said she's underage they
still didn't give a [ __ ]
that's how creepy these people get i'm
glad that she filmed this i'm glad that
she shed a little bit of light on this
because i think some people don't
realize how bad it can get yeah i got no
no easy solutions for the stuff like
this what do you think well
[ __ ] need to be talked to
that's the thing that's not so much they
need to be exposed so that we can talk
about it and we'll talk about the
different ways they're acting we need to
talk about that listen this
behavior is not
cool that's not what it is it ain't it
it's not it whatever you're trying to
achieve you're not gonna achieve it with
that okay you're not you know so we just
need to talk about it just the fact that
we're talking about it and we're
exposing it i mean that's part of it i'm
not saying that's the ultimate solution
and that's not the solution that's gonna
make a change within the next two to
three weeks in the short term but at
least we're gonna talk about it and that
ain't that ain't we've been saying that
since the beginning of this project
called abbott preach that this
cat-calling thing and the way they're
doing and the way you're doing that [ __ ]
that's that's lame that's lame it's more
than lame it's dangerous that that whole
energy here
nah not having it the best thing i could
say is this is people within your friend
group call them out on it
you best believe the people i rock with
don't say no [ __ ] like that and if i
caught them like we both would say
something right and so maybe that's the
biggest step that you as a man can take
in your individual life
um and if you feel like there's an
environment which you can come in and
make the woman safe as well as yourself
then definitely intercede right
obviously we did that video where there
was 20 dude surrounding a woman i said
hey don't go in by yourself and get
yourself killed but i mean if it's a
situation where you think you can help
and be of service whether it's calling
the cops or getting involved yourself
try
all right because at the end of the day
they are vulnerable when it comes to
stuff like this i know some people will
be like okay get get yourself a gun
people not everyone has access or lives
in places where you can have a gun which
unless i'm confirmed especially if she's
i'm a firm
believer yes get your guns okay i'm not
mad at it but it can be a solution for
everything you're a fan of mass huh
you're a fan of nas
nice you woke up this morning
got yourself a thumb
got yourself yo i'm living in this time
behind and these lines
but i get that but then she's in that
league she can't get
she's more difficult for sure because
it's more difficult she can't that's
that's not that so yeah
by the way so we just want to do this
video i thought it was important to talk
about this topic so let us know what you
guys think in the comments below we want
to hear from